Coffee discussion with dr. Bryan Keating
my name is Tony Darnell from deep
astronomy dot everything and we are here
to talk about I think we're here to talk
about exponential growth but I'm not
entirely sure so let me go ahead and
pull up let me pull out my guest dr.
Bryan Keating who's in his fancy Space
Station background hey Bryan how's it
going it's going great so nice Kate to
see you and talk with all the fans out
in the Internet that's right so if
everybody who if you're new to this
dream that we're doing on Thursdays then
let me just introduce dr. Bryan Keating
he has his own channel on YouTube dr.
Bryan Keating which you have know if you
do not subscribe to it you must the link
is in the description box below and he
and the reason is he really does some
outstanding content with respect to
interviews from from authors in the
fields of science and he's had some
amazing guests so far and we are the
purpose of this hangout is to introduce
you to not only Bryan but also his
channel and these interviews which I'm a
little bit confused Bryan are they part
of your YouTube channel or is this
really as part of the podcast that
you're doing which you should also
introduce yeah well basically I've
decided to take anything that I turn
into a YouTube video turn it into a
podcast or vice-versa originally we were
only doing audio interviews for the
arthur c clarke centers into the
impossible podcast and then i realized
we might as well do video interviews as
well and got some help from some
talented people here in san diego to add
in some footage some b-roll as they say
in the field and images and so forth and
and so we make it kind of an interactive
affair where we provide a lot of
resources and include things such as
show notes and links and so forth so
people can get access to all that my
website they sign up for my newsletter
you'll get access to the show notes and
my websites Bryan Keating comm and the
YouTube channel is Dr Bryan Keating and
so far yeah we've had on I think I've
read 20 books in the last 12 weeks I'm
starting to get a little cross-eyed well
it's uh yeah it's that
that's part of that's part and parcel of
the job though I I love that part of it
cuz you get to read some really cool
books so um so tell us a little bit
about that about today what what's the
topic for today and and while you're
talking I'm going to be doing some
behind the scenes button-pushing to get
the clip up that you sent me yeah yeah
please - so one of the things that I am
really really pleased to have access to
here in San Diego at the as the
co-director of the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination is our
board members and we have some
outstanding board members that advise us
including none other than than dr. peter
diamandis
famous futurist thinker university
chancellor founder founding CEO director
of the XPrize organization advisor to
companies spacex singularity or Z etc
and this is this phenomenal opportunity
that that I have I like to take
advantage of so I wanted to connect - to
Peter especially on the occasion of his
most recent book called the future as
faster than you think and how it's
really the third and the final third and
final in a series of books that began in
2012 with the release of a book called
abundance led to a book called bold and
now is part of a book called the futures
faster than you think and what's so
interesting about Peter is that he's
kind of the most pessimistic optimist or
the most optimistic pessimist I've ever
met and is simply a brilliant intellect
with the benefit of having advised
companies and so forth on how to really
make the future happen everything from
human longevity to a university the
future of universities which maybe we
can talk about - asteroid mining and
beyond it's just it's so much fun he
also has the distinction of being
Stephen Hawking's flight surgeon for the
first and only zero-gravity exploration
that Stephen Hawking ever took I
remember that
ok yeah well shall I just show the clip
now or do you want to
yeah why we do that yeah this is about
sir arthur c clarke and having that sir
ought to see Clark I believe oh here we
go this is really special your
recollections of arthur c-- clark you
mentioned that you he met him at at
least one occasion can you tell us a
little bit about so how'd you remember
him I met him in 1982 at I was a college
student I was at MIT that time and I
went to the United Nations conference on
the peaceful uses of outer space and he
was giving a talk and I was there with
two other colleagues Bob Richards and
Todd Holly toxins passed away and we
were there representing students but
exploration development of space sense
and wisdom
were there as the guest of David C Webb
one of our advisors and we ended up
befriending Arthur and long story on how
that happened but we're having dinner
with him and we over dinner were talking
about SEDs and our goals and our
missions and all of that and he was
telling us about the stories of
post-world War two his working with
German and Russian scientists and what
the world was like and ended up giving
him the moniker uncle Arthur and and he
agreed to become an advisor to says and
he then went from becoming an advisor to
said to becoming the Chancellor of the
international space university and I
would meet him every time it would come
to New York to focus on his next books
over there with 2010 was being filmed
and then I went twice to Sri Lanka to
meet him in Colombo and he was just an
amazing supporter of our work and it was
he had such a deep British voice to go
hello Peter yeah I can't do it but it
was it was I always just amazed
to get to know him alright that's your
recollections really awesome so yeah
that so I never got to meet Arthur Clark
but I did one I did always wanted to and
I certainly loved the books the that all
the all the books he's written you know
from all of it so I would that was a
great story yeah I have to say the title
of my podcast is the into the impossible
podcast and that really derives from one
of Sir Arthur C Clarke's famous Three
Laws the first one being any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
the second one being for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert
[Laughter]
he's got like five or six of them one of
them is if an elderly distinguished
scientist tells you that something is
possible he or she is most likely
correct if they tell you something is
impossible he or she is most certainly
wrong but his third law is the only way
to find out what is possible is to
venture a little bit beyond into the
impossible so hence the name of our
podcast and it really explores these
connections between society humanity's
greatest minds and how they do what they
do by overcoming things that once seemed
impossible to them and Peter is one of
these people what seemed impossible to
him so I think you know if I had a guess
with with Peter in the discussion that
we had really I would say nothing seems
impossible maybe living to like a
thousand is impossible but actually
achieving you know the following things
being an MD but not actually practicing
as a doctor nevertheless he received his
MD went to MIT he immediately went into
thinking about ways that what he calls
these exponential technologies could
revolutionize humanity and perhaps give
us a chance at if not true immortality
at least the extension of
life on earth the betterment of life on
earth and essentially achieving
immortality through his good works and I
think it's incredibly commendable what
he does he's really a uniquely as I said
super positive you know kind of
pessimist or super you know negative
optimist well what you mean in terms of
our future there he's an optimist in
terms of humanity's future and
technological futures think yeah yeah so
he has the so-called six DS which he
claims are these disruptive things that
are going to lead to an exponential
growth in the future and these are the
future will be digitized exponential
curves are deceptive because they
outpace linear growth only after some
period of time at first linear growth is
you know supersedes exponential growth
until that boom hockey-stick point takes
over we're all unfortunately more
familiar with exponential growth curves
than we ever were before thanks in some
small part to to this pandemic that
we're still dealing with he also talks
about how things can be d materialized
and put instead of you know dealing with
photographs and Kodak film you have
Instagram and Y that scaled so much
faster even though Kodak was one of the
original pioneers as you know of CCD
camera photography they never let go of
the materialized world that they were
inhabiting for 7080 years beforehand and
the other thing is you know his being
disruptive and being you know a pure
optimist I don't think those are
commensurate traits in other words you
can't say everything is great and the
status quo is great and say I want to
disrupt it right I mean imagine if you
know your wife says where marriage is
great but I'm gonna disrupt it like I
would be pretty nervous I know she
probably sometimes wants to do that my
wife but but but the point being he sees
life as it is as Ted Kennedy is rumored
to have said you know and dreams what
why you know what what could be made
different to achieve a dream of the
future that he especially wants he's a
child of the rocket age of the space age
of the Atomic Age and when I say he's
pessimistic its pessimistic towards
established the established institutions
let's take education
he's very pessimistic about the state of
education in Contra distinction to my
previous guests also at MIT David Kaiser
who's pretty optimistic that things will
continue status quo with a you know some
old sage on the stage scraping one piece
of rock on another piece of rock
you know chalk on a chalkboard I kind of
in between the two of them so piece
Peter is discussing ways that in the
interview that we had that things like
5g technology is going to revolutionize
how we educate people
augmented reality virtual reality on the
other hand he also thinks things like
cities and and transportation are going
to be revolutionized and I wonder you
know after kovat and I asked him about
this so you should watch it but you know
how did Cove it if at all change his
opinions that were so positive and
glowing about things like living in big
cities and you know being in mass
transportation and and so forth so
you'll have to listen to the interview
to find out did you discover when you
were talking to him any similarities
between his ideas and proclivities and
Ray Kurzweil he's very close with
Kurzweil obviously the name singularity
University is derived from of course
Wiles prediction somewhat that the
singularity is coming I didn't speak so
much about that I want to focus on his
book with Steven Kotler the future was
faster than you think actually did a
giveaway so anybody out there if you you
know want to get a copy of his book next
time or going back in time sign up for
my mailing list because you'll be
notified I give away books by these
authors today I'm giving away starting
the process of creating a giveaway for
my most recent guest professor Stephon
Alexander hopefully we'll talk about him
in a couple weeks on this show um so you
know to subscribe and and and join in
the fun to get notified about these
things because I really want to leverage
these amazing intellects that are coming
on my show on Monday I've got a Nobel
Prize winner coming on the show Adam
Reese yeah I have a guy in it yeah so
it's gonna be a and and just to engage
with them it's such a rare opportunity I
want my audience to ask me questions to
ask them so join the mailing list
stay in touch so some of the things that
that he talks about I think he's deeply
influenced by Ray but I wouldn't say
that they you know are a hundred percent
in lockstep I think I think of Ray is
kind of the the Steve Jobs kind of
visionary and I see Peter as also a
visionary but he's in the trenches doing
I'm not saying anything negative about
Ray but Peters founding universities on
the board of seven or eight different
corporations dedicated to human
longevity body improvement and and then
space exploration and with with the with
the with the s asteroid mining project
that he's involved in and he's got about
six or seven different companies I don't
know how he sleeps he's also got young
twins at home or not not super he's got
you know kid twin boys and and it's it's
he's really just a force of nature he
has a thriving online following he does
courses basically on LinkedIn and you
should follow him all around the
internet and it's yeah he's just he's
just a modern-day you know kind of
Nostradamus but a lot of his predictions
are you know are very potentially
impactful for how we live day to day as
well as you know for society as a whole
well I don't um I don't share the
optimism of a lot of these guys I think
that I read you know Kurzweil book and I
came awake thinking wow this is really
great but this is no way close to
happening and in some in some instances
this idea of exponential growth I think
we're not getting the full picture of
what is behind this because you know you
used the pandemic as an example that we
actually did not experience exponential
growth in that we we were able to blunt
that curve quite a bit by our behaviors
a little bit but it never really
achieved exponential goals because by
now we'd all have it that that's how
fast exponential growth occurs and so
I'm I just want to be a little I'm there
are other things in incurs Wilde's book
and I'm presumably in Peters book there
is this sense of once we're on this
curve boy all bets are off and we're
we're in the stars in
two weeks right because everything is
happening that fast and that's a very
good point and one thing I brought up
with him just because I always I'm
always respectful to my guests because I
don't think I can get more guests in the
future if I'm not respectful but I
always challenge them a little bit look
I said I said to Peter and I've said
this to other guests if you look at say
the predictions for say quantum
computing or these very org or Moore's
Law I mean that's the foundation of
exponential growth that things will take
off exponentially now if you look at the
actual number of transistors yes that's
that's held true yeah and the cost has
come down but in terms of the actual
throughput on a high throughput or high
performance computer it's actually
starting to saturate and the reason why
is it's a victim of its own success so
it can do if Tony were the only computer
user on earth of the San Diego
supercomputing Center
Gordon Flash Gordon computer which is
all based on flash memory and so forth
so super fast when it came out but then
it would be exponentially it would
continue this growth and flops and
floating-point instructions per second
however there's more than one Tony and
so the more successful this product is
the more exponentially larger numbers of
people want to use it and then you have
taxation you have overhead you have
throughput constraints and bottlenecks
economics it's the economics of scale
and and for me to think that yes it's
just this simple binary node tree that
just grows off forever
so yeah recognizes that I I was
impressed that he's not really you know
promoting things that are more prone to
hype say with with like quantum
computing quantum supremacy and stuff
like that
that really isn't in his book we did
talk about distribution which to me is
almost like the opposite you look at the
word decimate right where did that come
from it was like 1 in 10 people would be
killed in some Roman army or something
so it would be reduced by a factor of 10
that's kind of the opposite of that's
like exponential decay so every period
you lose 10% of the of the population in
this case he's talking about decimating
say transportation the book starts off
with an uber helicopter basically
that'll pick you up a drone that will
fly you around the city and you know the
day that we did the podcast I think it
was in like early March like uber
reached its lowest stock
price ever and I was thinking like how
is this really possible but then a month
later you know it's back to where it was
and the company's in good shape and
maybe it's suppressed some of its
competition because lifts and other
companies might go by the wayside so he
uses these paradigm dogmatic examples
virtual reality wearables like like
sensors that are becoming more and more
distributed I would say I agree about
half of what he's saying and I guess
given the scaling of some of the
predictions he's making it does lead to
a pretty bold and abundant future to use
the title of his previous two books yeah
okay but not almost none of this in my
opinion takes into account the the the
human nature because we there are plenty
of examples where we should by now
already have enjoyed the exponential
growth of so many things I'm thinking
Internet bandwidth is one of them right
we should all have gigabit speeds and
more all of us everywhere and yet we
don't because of purely economic
corporate and and human nature reasons
that have depressed all of this
exponential growth and none of it seems
to take any of this into consideration
what we can do and what we will do are
two entirely and completely different
issues and I the only these are these
thinkers tend to in my experience only
look at what we can do and not really
focus on what will end up happening and
I know that's way more complicated and
it is nice and it's easy to stay
optimistic that way when you think about
what we can do you can ignore all the
the crappy news about you know well it
won't actually happen because right
should abeyance should have been on the
moon consistently for 50 years yet or
not right so what we can't know what to
do was to the readings yeah I mean he
sometimes invokes these courts by
Einstein and and other people have
brought this up to you know this court
that two things are infinite the
universe and human stupidity and I'm not
sure about the universe and any see that
like I had there's a woman who wrote an
I bet in the Washington Post I'll try to
link to it in context of the you know of
what's happening in society with black
lives matter and and and racism and all
these conversations that are taking
place and she was saying like a witch
races and she's a scientist she's an
oceanographer and she was saying like
because of these problems that are
happening in society I can't do the work
that's needed for the climate and for
and for oceanography etc so how is it
possible you know for for me to do my
day job when I've got these human
factors that come into play I'll try to
find a link to it later but but the
bottom line is yeah you can be separate
out yeah you can't separate out the
society in which a scientist or
technologist or futurists lives and and
and that's society and his or her work
because we are both deeply connected to
the times in which we live in the
society in which we live but one thing
that's nice about the book that Peter
and Steven Kotler have written in this
series is that it does propane so what I
always do is look back at his previous
books which predictions came true which
attributes so certainly I don't think
you know right now at least in the case
of the kovat pandemic you know if you're
looking forward that you'd say yeah
cities are going to be the place for the
for people to live in the future they
have much lower overhead in terms of you
know housing costs transportation costs
but there are also open you up to new
potential pathogen vectors and
concentration etc so yes they may be
better energetically although there's
some controversy about that too however
if I look at education you and I have
had this conversation in the context of
Mario Livio when I talked about it with
him with Peter I said you know who would
you rather have me teaching you inclined
plane with a ball rolling down it or
Galileo himself by putting on a VR
headset and augmented reality and he's
very very positive about that he thinks
my job is my days of my job are numbered
that they really won't have the
opportunity for the traditional sage on
the stage I mentioned that's going to go
away according to him now I pushed him
back I said I have this virtual reality
headset Tony I've used it six times you
know my kids will use and I've had it
for two years now
and now you can get it for like 80 bucks
and it's great there's nothing wrong
with it but you know to wear this giant
headset around and then putting in
earphones and then like not being
disturbed for 3 hours maybe that'll work
but then I look what's the difference
right now at UCSD we're having virtual
labs can you imagine that here's a
virtual chemistry lab you know take out
your ear sodium hydroxide so fate and
mix it I I mean it's just insane but the
other classes are online and and now
kids are asking for tuition refunds for
for in-person schools and I can't dis
you know disagree with him I think
there's ripe for disruption in the
educational world and that's one of his
predictions it's gonna be completely
disrupted by technology such as 5g which
we can get into yeah I think that's a
good one thing that's a good prediction
too because you know I maybe maybe not
because of technology a little bit
because I didn't just out of sheer
necessity we are it is not an efficient
way I think the way that we're teaching
right now and well you know with all
respect all due respect to what you're
doing which is I think great in term in
the classroom it's important I think
your time could be best spent as a
professor working with your students in
a different way besides just standing in
a chalkboard and spewing out information
you can engage them in much different
ways now they could watch the video get
the content but you're there to teach
them what it means to teach them how to
interact with that content and to do
things with it to help enhance their
critical thinking that to me should be
where jobs like yourselves or should be
heading is this more it just uses your
time better and your expertise and skill
better because on lecture let's be you
know I mean universities have known for
decades that anybody can do it because
they hire you know I checked professors
with a higher lecturers to do it right
and that's all they do they just present
the material so good all right well what
I want to talk a little bit about this
idea of space travel and putting our
bodies into digital things and not
digital things but
mechanical things that have digital
components in them do you think that's
where we're heading
Kurzweil does and does Peter think that
too I think well he's working obviously
very hard space X PRIZE was one on the
first you know human commercial space
ventures that really propelled that
literally and figuratively into you know
suborbital flight back you know about
ten fifteen years ago now and the thing
that's brilliant about what Peter does
is he knows that you know what they used
to say about NASA no bucks no Buck
Rogers so there's actually a hedge fund
a venture capital fund that is
affiliated and allied with the XPrize
and it's called the XPrize Foundation
and they work to raise money for for
these prizes so fun fact that he shared
with me
the letter X stood originally an X Prize
as a placeholder for the eventual
foundation that would come in and give
them money to support the X prizes so
and you know be the Gordon Moore prize
or whatever of the Bill Gates prize but
instead he basically did it himself
through a venture capital funding and
then I urged people to go and take a
look at his website and so forth so you
know I think as far as where things
might be going with his with his you
know space ventures I think you know
he's done a few things with it so far
it's been space tourism very limited and
very expensive for the first people that
were on it
the first missions new Shaun sorry being
famous one she's first female space
tourists and she's on the board of the
XPrize foundation if not maybe the
leader right now I'm not sure and and so
they're working to you know make that
more what he calls democratized but I
think the pace you know is sort of
beginning to pick up I mean last weekend
we saw this wonderful launch of two crew
members for the first time to space and
then the return of the rocket I love
that back to her so I think you know
maybe that is in some way I mean Co
inspired by by what Peter has done
I don't know necessarily if that's his
top priority right now I think he spends
a lot of time focusing on that
all-important ingredient which is you
know financing these these
projects yeah yeah that's really true
it's uh you know your finances are huge
the huge obstacle for all this stuff and
so okay well listen we're we're up at
the end of our time together so let me
just look at some of the chat here do
you have some chat on your channel do
you want to respond to by the way
welcome everybody yeah I've been
watching your chats even though I
haven't publicly acknowledged you Andrew
planet galaxias back I haven't seen you
in a while it's good to see you back and
of course Peter Q and Susan hunter
Gregorius all you guys it's good to have
you back so I'll read some of your
comments and questions but let me just
give Brian a chance first you have
someone on your channel you want to
respond we are streaming to his channel
- yeah right yes let's see I don't see
too much any comments or questions here
let me see no I don't see any any
questions on my channel but let's go to
yours okay so a couple of comments David
Crane comments a pandemic spreads
exponentially when the reproduction rate
is over 1 if you keep are well above 1
for a while then you will see the virus
spread in the way Brian describes
that's Chris right but we'd haven't I
don't think well maybe in spots it's
gotten that high simon farmer i've
always been skeptical of Ray Kurzweil
but recent advancements in machine deep
learning that show capability increases
with scaling of computing as pudding
swing his pudding swinging me back into
his view one thing about Ray I have to
say is you know he's he's also gotten a
little bit controversial in some ways I
don't know if you're familiar with that
but one thing you know because he wants
to live the CETA to see the singularity
he's he's established a package of
supplements of vitamins and minerals
that you can buy called transcend I
won't I'll link to it I'm not I'm not
affiliated with it I just think you know
people are you know interested in this
and I should at least put it there so
people can make their own judgments
about it I'll put it in the in the in
the chat some people just take hold by
it
look I'm not averse to people if it's
not doing harm you know people take
vitamins for other reasons and take
other supplements for other reasons
other problem with that if it's
dishonest if it's disingenuous it is
yeah
yeah Leah let me know if you say if you
think it's it's dishonest yeah I put the
website again I don't have any
affiliation with it
I do take vitamins but not not his oh
yeah yeah here's what I think I think
that you know a couple things are
converging here we want to go into space
space is extremely dangerous and it is
very inhospitable to human beings we are
and so that's one thing another thing is
we are finely tuned to being here on
earth
extremely finely tuned to being here
even going in the atmosphere just a few
hundred miles away really messes us up
biologically and then going to the moon
get us out of the magnetosphere all this
stuff is is our biology betrays us and I
don't think we can survive space yeah I
think the only real practical way to get
there is to hope Ray and Peter at all
are reasonably close and that we can in
in somehow inject our bodies into a
thing that can survive space but that
opens up a whole bunch of philosophical
questions for me but let's say that's
possible you know then I think space
travel travel actually become something
we can talk about I am convinced we
conserve our space you know because you
look at you know all the projects
they're involved in you know human
longevity is a part of it and I think
you know I just put a link to some of
their probably you see is you know a
kovat XPrize basically now using big
data a high throughput computing can
help things they've also done the ocean
XPrize through the same woman's who's up
scientist who's op-ed I posted earlier
from the Washington Post about how
racism is impeding her work and climate
change she's involved with a company
that did that did participate or maybe
one part of an X Prize a few years ago
and the ocean sciences so and I think
personally there's more opportunities
for life under water or you know if
we're looking for things but of course
it doesn't get much more as much
attention as you know going to Mars and
colonizing Enceladus and so forth so I
tend to agree with you it's a lot of its
kind of escapist wishful thinking um
but at least no under and I started
talking to Peter you know let's say you
cure all these things and we have this
lifespan that's a healthy lifespan which
they call a health span and it goes out
to 180 or 200 first of all how
democratic will that be will it only be
for the richest people and let's say it
is for the richest people or you know
people that can afford to do it or
sacrifice their time or whatever nothing
wrong with that the first you know play
the first plasma TVs cost twenty
thousand dollars and now you can't even
buy one because they've been superseded
by better technology however what will
that do to the people that that have
nothing else to lose in other words if
you can't die because your genes have
been perfected your telomeres have been
trimmed and and coiffed and whatever I
don't know what they're gonna do I'm not
a biologist but but then you're gonna
live in fear I think like you could be
killed or you could you know die in a
car crash what will that do to our human
psyche so I think that the technology is
actually outpacing by far how it will
impact us as human beings and that's
something you touched on earlier and you
know I think I think you can go
blissfully into technology space as I
always do with my colleagues and then
this week you know just to be honest
with all the listeners we were really
grappling with this awful situation
that's going on in society we didn't get
much work done on the Simons Observatory
in terms of you know researching the
cosmos because we had more pressing
concerns and how to deal with this awful
situation on earth and what are we gonna
do we're just cosmologists the answer is
we can do a lot in our own community in
the community of cosmology and so I'm
proud to say where we're starting
fellowships in partnership with the
National Society of black physicists and
we're working to give internships to be
a partner with this gust institution
which I'm proud to say I'm a member of
and this week's podcasts that I just
launched today I - this week one one was
about the founding of Instagram kind of
like the social network but for
Instagram it's fascinating story by
sarah fryer had her on on monday and
then today i released that interview
with one of my best friends in the whole
world professor Stephon Alexander who's
the president of the National Society of
black physicists I'm gonna give away his
book so please you know tune in to that
interview subscribe to show notes and
and so forth or any other questions that
we can
got five more minutes okay uh
interplanet is asking isn't AI already
here with us humans we are the first AI
I think he Peter I asked him about that
you know how do you see AI and advancing
what kinds of things will advance is the
next step and I think he thinks it's
it's things like these you know
listening devices and it'll be like a
doctor in a doctor's remember he's a
physician so your your view of a
physician typically when you go to the
doctor's nowadays some person that's
doing this it was just like typing never
looks at you you know but imagine if in
your doctor's office there's a there's a
virtual smart assistant I won't say the
name mine because she's listening as I
speak and as I type and I don't want to
upset her but could be listening in the
doctor's office on scanning through oh
he mentioned he's got a problem with his
left
you know gluteus maximus and and that
correlates in ninety-seven percent of
people who are as his age weight genetic
type DNA whatever that correlates to you
know a severe lack of exercise
I don't know whatever it'll be but that
AI will be integrated everything will be
integrated all of your data your sensors
your phone your voice patterns your
stress anxiety that that's the direction
that AI can help an immediate sense but
it needs to improve and it needs to be
you know massively made more available
to increase the sample size from just
the very fortunate few that are involved
in it now I joke with him I have this
aura ring I don't know if you ever heard
of these aura rings these are like sleep
trackers I got this thing's like 200
bucks or something and and he's like
yeah it's really expense I said did you
get this one did you get the one that
I'm wearing you know it's clear one
still he's like no I got a guy was like
[Laughter]
oh that's great well yeah I mean I don't
know this I'll leave I'll leave you with
Andrews question then you can head out
what about digitizing genomes then take
them on board a spaceship and when you
get to a world where life could
physically exist transfer the digital
genome into a biological one as in
artificial wombs
Wow Andrew there's a lot there
[Laughter]
yeah I guess you know that is sort of
what we've been doing as a species
except it's been transported in time in
that space I guess the question is you
know when does that actually come to
come to fruition in terms of
distributing throughout the cosmos I'll
tell you what tomorrow I'm talking with
Andrew Ryan on the podcast she's Carl
Sagan's Widow and also the creator of
the cosmos possible world series I could
ask her about that and maybe you and I
like Toni we'll talk about in the future
that conversation that we have you know
about 20 episodes that we need to talk
about including one that I did last week
that didn't get much attention because I
just released on a Friday with a good
friend of mine a professor from the
University to Chicago about the so
called detection of a parallel unit yeah
strange particles in Antartica so look
that oh yeah that was did in a real
scientist
you know who's working at the boundary
he's a human imagination yeah so Abby
beer Greg okay it's her name and so
check out that interview I'll put a link
right now yeah thank you
chat okay cool so we will yeah that
particular story I thought got
ridiculous fast so I would like to hear
what what she has to say for sure okay
well I guess I will let you go dr. Brian
soda are you there
yeah yeah are you cutting out you're
starting to cut out I don't know it
doesn't look like it's me are you having
ISP issues okay Tony you still there
yeah I'm still here we can still see you
but you maybe you're you're cutting out
and becoming quite digitized so I guess
we'll let you go go ahead and and again
disconnect and we will we will talk to
you next
oh well next week I do actually have a
hangout
so we'll be enough to be in two weeks
from next week so whatever is what is it
June 18th okay yeah can you hear me yeah
I can hear you can you hear me you're
cutting you're cutting out no yeah sorry
so yeah I was